- [Interviewer] All right
Louis where you from?`
- [Louis] My name is Louise I
grew up in Compton California.
- [Interviewer] Now tell
me about your family
you grew up with both your parents?
- [Louis] I grew up-
For the first...well part of
my life I grew with both my parents.
My ah... Mother was kind of
little off with the in brain
kind of timid, but very good looking.
My dad was a very smart dude
he had a real good job as engineer.
And... He also had a...
Pool hall business on the side
in fact he had a couple of them.
My grand dad had one too.
They where cunning.
Where they were smart in the books
and then smart on the... Streets also.
I grew up as a little child we had four-
We had four siblings at first.
So my dad had about 30 kids
we were the four that my mother had.
- [Interviewer] Your
dad had how many kids?
- My father had about 30 kids.
I know by the end my father
had about 30 kids.
From 30 different women but
my mother had four of them.
So they...They would
fight all the time.
And he traumatize me to this day.
I don't like to see a women-
I would think I not to see
a man hit a women.
And I grew up, as I
tell at the end of the story,
being the same way cause
I beat the shit out of them sometimes.
I mean I beat the fucking shit
out of them sometimes.
And I cry after I do because
I don't know why I do it
but now when I think back when
about this stuff that I use to do
it makes me rage, rage.
So anyway I started to growing up.
And when I started to grew up-
(word stuttering)
I was always called "the punk,
the square, the pussy, the sissy"
I was always the square,
this punk kid nobody be liking.
I was ugly, and I wear glasses
and people just didn't like me.
So I grew up inside just
being hurt and just being
incredibly angry inside
and remorseful and I thought
I hated the way I look,
I hated where I was,
I hated my family.
We grew up we moved to
a bigger city in Brentwood.
When we got there, my father
really got bad with my mom
he started beating my mom.
But if you looked outside
of the house we always had-
we had 911 Porsche in the driveway.
If you went into the house
my dad had guns all
around the house.
My mother had knots all
over her head and stuff
where my dad use to beat her.
And the rest of the kids
was complaining and all
kinds of stuff.
I remember my mother went
to the police station in Compton
to get the police and the police
said there ain't nothing we can-
They looked at my mother
sitting there with black eyes.
And then said they couldn't
do nothing for her.
I hated the fucking police.
I hated, I hated the
fucking police since then.
They wouldn't help my mother.
So I grew up, I remember wanting
to go in there.
I remember thinking about
taking a knife and going in there
and stabbing the shit out
of my daddy for beating my mom.
I wanted to take knife
and stab his motherfucker ass.
I wanted to kill that motherfucker.
Dammit I feel I just want to-
Just go in there blow
his fucking head off.
So one day he his guns
in his drawer I went down
and took one of
his fucking guns.
And he jumping on my
mother and I took
the fucking gun out.
Didn't know what I was
going to do with it.
When I went to motherfucking ass.
Something hit my hand
and the fucking gun went off.
(Gun re-enactment)
I shot at the roof of the house
and the police came that's
my first time going to jail.
And here I am nine years old,
10 years old they
were trying to tried-
(word stuttering)
I tried to kill my father
but I really didn't try
to kill my father.
So they put me in school
they put me like a-
It wasn't a charter school
back then it was like a
remedial school, remedial class
for problem students
and I never would talk,
I never would talk,
I never ever would talk.
I remember my mother said
that they put me-
she come to school to
see how I was doing
I was standing in the
corner all by myself you know.
As I got older they started
calling me Jason because
I never smiled, I never look.
But I wanted to kill everybody,
I hated everybody,
I wanted to kill everybody.
And really blame society
about everything that going
on with my life.
There were people in my life-
the people in my life that love
like my grandmother and they
started to die.
I really went crazy because
I feel like I didn't have nobody
you know cause my dad
didn't want nothing to
do with me, he thought
that I was sorry to him,
I was stupid to him.
Told me I was stupid, I was dumb,
I was worthless,
I was never going to be nothing.
I didn't see it that way.
When we moved out of Compton
we moved into this white neighborhood.
I notice I started to
hang out with the white guys.
I started to want the black girls
because when I was going
to school Compton, the kids
would take-
One kid took a scissor
tried to cut my ear off.
They kept me they would
take me around the building,
they would beat me up.
And stuff like that and
call me a pussy.
But when I got to the whiter
neighborhood schools, the white
kids didn't do that
they accepted me they accepted
in their houses and everything.
So I literally wanted
to be white.
I wanted to be like back
in the day I wanted
to be like Michael Jackson.
I wanted to paint my skin white.
I hated being black.
I hated the word nigga.
To me the word nigga
fit blacks just right.
But I felt like I
wasn't one of them motherfuckers.
I was different I even
thought in my head.
I remember my grandmother said
onetime, she said " I never known
a nigga in my life wanted
to be white like Donald.
My grandson wants to be a white boy."
And I did cause I hated blacks,
I hated fucking black people.
So I grew up and I remember-
(word stuttering)
I was scary-
I was always scared to fight.
I was just scared to fight.
I remember my first girlfriend
she slap me in the face like a bitch.
(slap impersonation)
I like you man but you a punk.
You never yell, you never cuss,
you don't call me a bitch.
What's wrong with you?
You just a sissy.
(slap impersonation)
She slap me again.
Then I turn into fucking-
(word stuttering)
Something came onto me.
I remember we took her
friend to go to school
by the balcony and I remember
I took her by the neck.
And I had the bitch by
her fucking neck.
And I said "Bitch what you say?
You fucking bitch what did say?"
I remember she was real light skin
I remember her face turn real blue
and her eyes were like green
her eyes started to turn green.
I really don't like
talking about this cause
it kind of traumatize me,
But I didn't kill her.
I almost killed her.
So there was one more
time where I was going
to jail for attempted
murder you know.
My mom got me
out of that one.
So then...They started
to send me to a psychiatrist
I always had bad eyes
but I had good ears.
I overheard the psychiatrist saying,
"You better watch him"-
(word stuttering)
"This guy is going to
be some kind of cereal, rapist,
murder or something like this."
I heard that shit you know.
And when I went to school,
I went school, and I remembered
they always had me in a
remedial classes you know
the classes where the teachers
send you-
I remember one of my friends
said "hey man that's Don Juan
he goes to the nut room,
they send him to the nut room."
(laughing)
The nut class.
Because I always went
to the remedial classes.
So big Lou like me-
So then when I got to the fifth grade.
A friend of mine named Joey.
Well he wasn't my friend
he would always beat me up
he would grab me by the
neck and take me down the street.
He would say "We're going to
steal pizza, we're going to
take it, we're going to
steal pizza."
I was so scared of him.
I remember this big girl
named Linda said "Oh Louis,
you going to let him
punk you like that?"
I told him "You not going
to punk me in front
of a girl."
So I pick up, way down
on a baseball court and
I took a baseball bat,
and I went upside
his fucking head.
And when I hit him
in the head, I remembered
seeing two knots
on the side of his
fucking head.
And when he hit the ground,
I saw him convulsing
and I kind of like that shit
you know I kind of
like shit.
Something out in me
and I kind of like
that shit.
I'm like damn
I should have did more
motherfuckers like that.
(Word Stuttering)
As I got older I started
to smashing bugs and
you know I remembered
I through a dog
out the car when the
car was going down
the street one day.
I remembered I went horseback riding
onetime and the fucking
the horse, he jump over the-
Jump over something where he jump
hit my legs, his legs caught the
thing and he fell down.
And I remembered
beating the horse up.
We were in a little town
called Karvey Texan.
When they held down.
The police had to hold me down
they said that the look
on my face was like evil,
was like fucking evil.
And I remember the
horse was doing the-
(horse impersonation)
The more he hollered,
the I fucking liked it.
The more I fucking like it.
I remembered they molested me.
They fucking molested me.
The baby sitter down the
street fucking molested me,
fucking molested me.
And the fucked up thing
about this shit
because I like it.
I liked it because I was
a little kid I couldn't
tell nobody.
I couldn't tell nobody
the lady down the street
was making put face between her legs.
I couldn't tell nobody the lady down
the street was sucking on my
dick every damn night
every other night.
When come she tell momma
you don't have to pay me.
Because some kind of way she
was going to do some crazy shit.
No, so one day I thought I was
going to be slick.
I wanted the girl next door.
I took her in the back yard,
I doing it to her in the back yard.
Next thing I know here come
the fucking cops.
(siren re-enactment)
"What are you doing?"
Oh I must of been 14, 13 or 14.
I don't know what fuck I'm
doing I'm down here
with this girl.
The girl underage.
The girl was nine years old.
They got me for that.
I went a year for that.
I got in the jail for that.
As time kind of went on.
I got an order.
(word stuttering)
I never was social
playing cards anhit like that.
I remember my cousin saying,
"Hey man, take a shot of this,
take drink of this shit,
and take hit of this shit.
And everything is going
to be all right."
I took a shot of that Gin
and I remembered playing-
they teach me how to play cards
I don't know how to play spades,
I don't know how to socialize,
I never had friends,
never had friends.
If you ever heard
anybody back in the day,
nobody knows my name, nobody
knew my name, nobody
knew anything about-
(word stuttering)
I wanted you to sit, and
how I wanted crack
your fucking head,
I wanted to run over with a car.
I wanted to-
(word stuttering)
fuck your wife,
I wanted to do your girlfriend
maybe your daughter or something
this crazy.
This is where my mind was going
when I be looking at your-
but I look like this innocent
little kid nobody really knew.
I was fucking, I was mess,
I was a wreck, I was a wreck.
So my mind started
to get godless crazy shit
in my head.
So finally when-
Oh back to the card game.
I learned how to play cards.
And when they taught
me how to drink,
they taught me how to drink gin.
I remember drinking gin.
I remember I drink the gin
until I threw up.
I threw up all over
the girls floor
and they cleaned it up
and the first thing I
said after that,
I remember the the ceilings
and shit was going around.
And the first thing I said,
"Lets get another one."
I was an alcoholic from
the fucking start.
They put joint in mouth,
"hey man hit the fucking joint."
I hit fucking and saw stars
my whole head went all the way around.
I didn't have to
think about being molested
no more, I didn't blasting
no more, I didn't think
about killing nobody no more
cause I was free, I was free then.
I got a good job, I got a sports car.
I was rolling around, but I was still
drinking, I was still using.
Then whole comes to day, we
were all at this one house
at Torrance California.
And the girls said
they were all smoking crack
back then it was called "Rock"
in Compton.
I wanted the little light
skin girl, I wanted to
get the light skin girl
she was smoking
she said, "If you want
to do something with
you got to hit this."
I don't want to hit that shit
what the hell are you guy doing?
They got glass pipe in it
and smoking the shit.
I hit the shit.
Everybody had to get out
of the house.
I'm all alone now
I got my crack.
Fuck you, fuck everything
I got my crack now.
Yes I talking about, this had
to be fucking 30, 35 years ago.
That motherfucker been
my best friend ever since.
telling me what to do,
telling how to do it.
Making me lose everything
my life and gaining it back.
I've been to rehab I know-
I've been to 50 rehabs
I can quote the big book,
I can quote the Bible.
How much of that shit
do I live? None of it.
So what made me end
coming downtown,
I a pretty good job.
Real good job.
(Word Stuttering)
matter of fact I had to drive
up southern pacific
switching tracks every
now and then driving train
had a real good job.
I fucked it up cause
they were pissed at me.
Had a real good job, they
wanted put me on a truck one
day, put me on a 18
wheeler send me all over the country.
I did that for minute.
I end up pissing dirty on that.
So I ended up stopping that
and then I had a really good job.
What I really do good
is I paint well.
I was up in Hollywood painting.
On any penny paint.
Friend of mine was smart.
Guy had some nice cars.
I got my car stolen.
I got beat up.
I got shot that was
on seven street onetime
walking down the street
on a Sunday afternoon,
the guy pulled up
in a car.
I had no idea,
he looked at me,
and he shot.
(gunshot re-enactment)
I got one in the leg,
I got one in the hand,
I got hit one in here,
and I got three in
the back.
About three in the back.
I still didn't stop smoking crack.
I still smoke crack.
Anyway I ended up down here.
Two years I was down here
it was pouring down
fucking raining, pouring
down fucking rain.
I had know where to stay,
I said God where ever you are,
where you are.
If you exist, if you exist.
Forgive me for all the crazy
stupid shit that I did.
All the crazy-
I confess everything, about
the girls, about the guys,
about the guns,
about the shooting,
about the killings,
about the chokings.
About the animal I killed,
about the people I stomped out.
About the girl I ran up with the car.
About how I had three married women,
had three married.
(word stuttering)
One of there
husbands caught me.
Caught me and her
in his truck one day.
That when I knew it was God
When that guy pulled
us over in that car he said,
"What the fuck you doing
in my wife's car?"
And I remember he was
on this of the car
and I was on this side
she lied and said, "This
is my friend my cousin."
He said, "Bitch you know I'm-"
he said," Hey man, get
out of my motherfucking car."
Mind you this guy
had a nickname "Mike Tyson"
he look like him, he was
built like a gorilla.
He came to the car he said,
"Hey man, get the fuck out my car."
Now I grabbed the handle
on the door to get out
the goddamn car, this
part of my body-
But my legs said we
ain't going no fucking where.
I was so scared my legs
was shaking like this,
I couldn't get out the car.
I'm like come on I couldn't
get out of the car.
He ran around the other
side of the car he said,
"You lucky I'm on broad if I
ever see you with my wife
again motherfucker okay
Mr.Louis, I'm going kill,
I'm going to kill you!"
So I quit messing with that girl.
I was staying in Texas
I came all the way home.
I was so scared that dude-
Till this day that happen...
13, 14 years ago till this day
I'm still scared he's going
to run up on one day.
Cause you know I
was banging his wife,
me and his wife was banging.
She was buying me, she bought me cars,
she bought me cloths, she bought
me everything she just bought everything.
She wanted to get a house with me.
So anyway we still tried
to get together, but he would
call her on the phone,
"Are you with that motherfucker?
Are you with that motherfucker?"
No, so anyway I quit doing that.
Back to getting closer--
I ask God to forgive me
for that stuff I did.
All the demoralizing, incompetent,
all the molestation, and
all that shit I went through,
and all the crazy shit and
I asked him to forgive me.
I said, "God help get some
fucking where to stay.
If you fucking real. This
is what you going fucking do."
About a week later Trump came
in town with a helicopter.
Somebody said he looked down
and said, "I want to know why all
these people are down here?
Why all these people-
I know you guys-
I know California y'all
don't like me.
But I give enough money
that you can better my people."
(word stuttering)
Everybody talking about
Donald Trump.
Donald Trump talked about us.
He spoke for me he said,
"I give my people enough money-
(word stuttering)
So they don't have to live like this.
I'm going to send scouts."
So when he said scouts
I went to church that day
and guy said, "If you want a place
to stay come in with your pay work."
(hand clapped)
I had place in two days.
Most people come and have
five or six years trying
to get a place.
That means that somebody doing
something wrong with
their fucking money.
It was fucking Donald Trump
who got me a motherfucking place.
Thanks a lot Donald Trump.
Fuck what they say about you.
I'm voting for your
motherfucking ass again.
But anyway, that how I
ended up down here.
So now know I'm
chill kind of moonlight
you know I relapsing
every now and then
doing this shit.
Hey I'm lonely as fuck
I ain't got no girl
you know I'm using
my hand a lot.
But hey that's cool too.
We can say, we can
say that on YouTube.
This is YouTube, I'm Louis Vanny, I'm out.
- [Interviewer] So let
me ask you question two.
Um, so the behavior
all the crazy stuff you
just laid out.
- There's a lot more but I-
lot, lot more there so much.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think that came from
your... that kind of behavior in your dad?
- Oh yes definitely.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your dad and
his relationship with you
and siblings?
- He's a mean motherfucker.
He's a mean mother-
Smart this motherfucker-
this motherfucker is so smart,
but he's a mean motherfucker
would beat your ass,
whoop your ass knock you
out in a motherfucking heartbeat.
- [Interviewer] How he treat your sisters?
- He treated... I don't know maybe
he was messing around, maybe
he was bother them I don't know.
But I don't know.
But I know he use to beat the
fuck out of me.
Beat the fuck out of my brothers,
and beat the fuck out of the them.
He was a... Just a mean motherfucker.
He's not with us anymore
God bless him.
I love him to death but
I miss him sometimes.
Sometime I don't,
Sometime I say motherfucker
your ass need to be going the
fucking dirt your motherfucking
ass did.
- [Interviewer] Thanks
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.